the worst one is nice guys finish last
it's taught people in the world that you
can't be a good person while building a
big business but another really bad one
right is I forgot but I'll get back to
it in a
second I'm so passionate about the nice
guys finish last that it bothers me
temp I'm going to go with it I'll get
back to it in a minute but what I really
really really need oh I got
it they tell you not to work with
friends and family I stand here today as
someone who lives it but more
importantly has invested in over a
thousand businesses his life analyze
business the way people analyze movies
and sports it's my hobby I couldn't be
more bullish hiring friends and family